et vous pensez que c'est quoi
aujourd'hui chez les Français c'est de
la résignation c'est de la peur qui
conduit à la lâcheté ou c'est de la
naïveté face à ce qui est en train de se
passer il faut regarder la classe
politique vous avez une classe politique
qui est lamentable d'accord à part
quelques personnalités voilà à droite
comme à gauche mais en gros c'est pas
terrible c'est à eux de de mobiliser
c'est à eux de dire mais c'est vrai que
vous avez il sont encore entendabl
aujourd'hui les poli non surtout la
gauche la gauche qui a délaissé la
laïcité alors peut-être que là c'est en
train de rebouger mais si vous voulez
quand il y a eu cette espèce de
tergiversation maladroite malsine mais
oui le Hamas c'est une c'est c'est du
terrorisme oui le Hamas fait du mal y
compris et avant tout aux Palestiniens
d'accord et là vous avez eu des espèces
de de rondeurs machin machin mais ils se
rendent pas compte vous appelez ça des
rondeurs vous le fait de pas qualifier
le Hamas de terrorisme c'est n'importe
quoi ils se sont trompés d'ailleurs ça a
coulé laanupe là bon et ben des gens de
gauche comme moi on est orphelin quelque
chose or il faudrait il faudrait des si
vous voulez des des joress parce que
l'histoire de la gauche c'est ça c'est C
joress c'est les discours de de miterran
c'est c'est tout ça de la grandeur de
l'humanisme la laïcité et de combattre
ce qui se
passe